[Musik]
die schule stellte mich sagen der lage
zusammen ich glaube dass ich damit sie
haben eine gute truppe die mich
kommen wir aber die ganze stadt und land
nur einen und geworden aber ich war
darüber aber ich wollte leben oder
überleben
vom luxus diese frage zu stellen hand
und dieser film
[Musik]
diese geschichte beginnt in einer
wunderbaren villa in der karibik mit
1500 quadratmeter wohnfläche gebaut von
berühmten designern
es gibt einen billard saal und ein kino
und dazu einen spektakulären pool mit
sicht auf senken gemietet hat dieses
anwesend patrick liotard folgt 29 jahre
alt haushälterin und koch inklusive
[Musik]
der erbe einer familie der zürcher
goldküste machte anfangs 2014
schlagzeilen mit gescheiterten
geschäften und betreibungen von 4
millionen franken
ein paar monate später scheint alles
ganz anders verstanden wieso der
zusammenhang gemacht wird auch betriebe
und hat das finanzielles problem weil es
bestätigt sie und rief könig vielleicht
nicht wollen
ich trete zusammenhang zwischen dem
lappen steht und eine betrieben
liotard vogt habe sich in die karibik
abgesetzt hieß es in der presse
tatsächlich besitzt er jetzt einen
karibischen pass ist abgemeldet in der
schweiz pendelt aber hin und her
die betreibungen seien erledigt nur in
einem fall kommt es zu einem
gerichtsprozess erfolgt nach eigenen
angaben für 20 millionen franken anteile
an einem luxus-resort gekauft
er glaubt an eine große zukunft der
insel
der schweizer spielte der superstar
venture merial absolute katastrophe
hast du dir da ich bin der amerikanische
touristen am abend mit stöcken und
turnschuhe
wieso sein konto nicht optimal und haben
und klar präsentiert das wird richtig
kurzum vor hinter von mir zum
familienstand sky aber vor allem zum
teil auf die insel
rückblende vor vier jahren galt er als
schillernder jungunternehmer er genoss
die publizität und erzählte gerne dass
er an dutzenden von firmen beteiligt
seien
erstaunlich denn seine ausbildung ist
eher bescheiden
nach zwei jahren sekundarschule
bezahlten die eltern einen aufenthalt an
einer der exklusivsten privatschulen der
schweiz in müllrose liotta brach die
ausbildung ab genauso wie eine zweite
privatschule erst später schaffte er ein
anderes diplom und einen patch war in
finance
[Musik]
der märchenhafte aufstieg wurde damit
erklärt dass sein großvater und sein
urgroßvater ceos von nestle waren
der enkel habe viel geld geerbt jutta
voigt spricht nicht gerne darüber
das sei privatsache sagt er also ich
glaube dass einziges statement nicht mal
gemacht das ist erstaunlich ist dass ich
damals führt gründig vereins gab sich
frankreich an das ist korrekt sitze
jetzt mehr als 7
das ist das ist ein fakt jedenfalls
scheint es so dass geld vorhanden ist
gummi saint kitts zu investieren
patrick liotard ist ein guter netzwerker
unter schafft es immer wieder leute von
seinen hochfliegenden plänen zu
überzeugen
ja aber das ist schon bitter hat und
dass man besonders freut hand machen wie
vielen anderen große freude damit die
ganze jobs kreiert und die will die der
will die teil von der insel
ökonomisch nicht erbringen
an erhöhter lage mit blick aufs meer
entstehen 100 private villen vier hotels
und ein golfplatz für die gehobene
klientel wird übernachtung im luxushotel
über 2000 dollar kosten
die kaufpreise für appartements und
villen liegen zwischen 400.000 und vier
millionen dollar gesamtwert der anlage
600 millionen bis jetzt ist sein kids
noch eine karibikinsel ohne große
anziehungskraft doch sie hat ein
umstrittenes geschäftsmodell das viel
geld bringen könnte
wer für mindestens 400.000 dollar
investiert zum beispiel ins luxus
ressort erhält den pass von sind kids
und damit die staatsbürgerschaft patrick
liotard hat deshalb einen berater im
schlepptau der reiche kunden vermittelt
stellen sie sich einen erfolgreichen
geschäftsmann vor aus einem politisch
instabilen lang er kann mit seinem pass
nicht ohne diesen reisen er will seine
familie schützen indem er hier in
immobilien investiert wo er ein
lebensstil kauft aber auch einen pass
mit dem er ohne visum in 130 länder
reisen kann inklusive schengen-staaten
und kampf das ist der globale bürger
ein weiterer vorteil der karibikinsel
es gibt weder einkommens noch
vermögenssteuern
aber was ist wirklich lyon diese rolle
sicher sein ruf als reicher erbe helfen
das luxus resort zu vermarkten
indes kursieren viele falschmeldungen
so schrieb eine zeitung liotta habe 600
millionen in das projekt investiert und
auf einer webseite der regierung heißt
es liotta sei der besitzer von nestlé in
der dritten generation
inzwischen hat er mir das du angeboten
war aber bei fragen zu seinen finanzen
bleibt er auf distanz
wir haben starkes und stecke hinter sich
also und aber sie schmerzen und ich
glaube ich habe noch eine dvd natürlich
linie einheiten greift dann hat die
möglichkeit dass man sich da mit der
regierung die regierung kraft und ich
hatte die chance genutzt und
mittlerweile an irakern
aber das ist geld wo du vorher
erarbeitet hat das ist riskant da
investiert ja also ich habe kein anderer
investor wenn das wenn das tragisch und
wir haben ja dann frei und ermöglicht
und das ist das ziel und ich glaube
sogar dass der mann sich gearbeitet
sondern sehr positiv gestimmt dass man
da noch bis kurz weiter verlieren
ab und zu ist lothar in der schweiz am
zürichsee hat ein büro an bester lage
gemietet eingerichtet im karibischen
stil und mit einer spektakulären
seesicht
die meisten seiner beteiligung habe eher
abgestoßen er konzentriere sich jetzt
nur noch auf ein paar wenige sagt er
dahindümpelt und potenzielle wie sich
marburg und dann schussbahn hatte
eigentlich ist es fertig aber es ist
eben eine querte gelebter glaube vor
vier jahren stieg er ins
kreditkartengeschäft 1
er kaufte 18 prozent der diners club
kreditkarten lizenz für einige
europäische länder
er hoffte die etwas in vergessenheit
geratene marke zu neuem glanz zu bringen
zusammen mit dem ceo besichtigte er die
neuen büros und das finde ich das für
die super spannend doch das geschäft
wurde ein flop
jetzt hieß er und sein sie hätten viel
geld in den sand gesetzt
die bezugspreise in zweistelliger
millionen betrag
das ist dabei der sich kreisky ist dass
das was das war schon jetzt sein helfer
einiges besser laufen aber weg sei
weniger ich möchte gerne gesprochen
was ist schiefgelaufen die und
experience gern aber wie viel kostet
habt oder gesteckt oder dass sich ich
muss mich auch ihrem eigenen verfolgt
die firma gezeigt was er sich und jetzt
nicht eine schweizerisch schweiger
im jahr 2009 es ist die zeit der
schweinegrippe grassiert bartl theodor
volk zusammen mit einem arzt das hand
desinfektionsmittel sind mit geo tag
bietet ein bombengeschäft
die idee das alltags produkt das wir ein
paar franken zu kriegen ist tolle
verpacken und als lifestyle-produkt für
24 franken verkaufen
[Musik]
das ist jetzt das erste produkt wenn man
fremd ihres produktes
wir haben darauf beharrt dass das cool
und flora dabei die farbe und das ist
jetzt ein wichtiger mann mitte 40 noch
wandert einem ding draus trainierter
sprach damals von vorbestellungen im
umfang von 50 millionen franken
doch es kam anders das mittel war zu
teuer um ein renner zu werden
der beteiligte arzt sagt heute hätte
sich blenden lassen
dann habe mit zu grosser kelle
angerichtet ich würde das mal anders und
vor allem als texterin mich sind
wirklich auf guttenberg sie organisch
wachsen bis die schweinegrippe und mich
nach der op das wird so weitergehen
nicht antizipiert das alle sofort
produziert und günstiger sind ja ich
weiss auch er anders machen
wir sind mit einem blauen auto fuhr
trotz dieser rückschläge scheint patrick
liotard weiter obenauf zu schwimmen
er verweist auf frühere internet
beteiligungen will aber nicht in die
details gehen
absam kitts nevis esther schillernde
schweizer unterdessen in den höchsten
kreisen angekommen
in seiner villa empfängt er den
premierminister von saint kitts mit
seiner assistentin aus privatgäste
[Musik]
diese aussicht ist unglaublich ja nicht
wahr obwohl ich hier lebe habe ich nicht
genug zeit und gelegenheit für solche
momente waren sie schon einmal hier
nein das ist mein erster besuch den
premierminister freut es dass wir geld
investiert das projekt war in
finanzielle schieflage
die regierung unterstützte es und
verkauft ihren anteil später an den
schweizer
im jahre 2005 merkten wir dass unsere
zuckerrohr industrie wegen der
globalisierung nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig war
wir mussten aussteigen und schufen einen
fonds der unter anderem projekte
tourismus unterstützen sollte so wurde
einer der neuen wirtschaftlichen
schwerpunkte von senke sikom tores
seemannes verteidigte services
unterdessen hat der premierminister
lothar zum persönlichen berater gemacht
ausgestattet mit diplomatenpass da ist
diese 29-jährige gut aussehende und
charmante junge wie hat er es geschafft
sie nachher an den premierminister zu
kommen
wir sehen ihn als den neuen typ von
investor type of investors
er ist kein pirat his daughter parasit
werner
[Gelächter]
er ist ein teil von uns hier bekamen
paten kassel
er ist jetzt ein bürger vor sind jetzt
seine von uns ist es ein einheimischer
quasi has been akzeptiert es wurden auf
us und ich bin in sein haus gekommen
weil ich ihn als einen freund ansehe und
aufgaben dieses haus picasa sie haben es
ja so fremd und so hält patrick liter
folgt seinen aufwendigen lebensstil
aufrecht wenn er in der schweiz ist
bringt ihn ein fest angestellter fahrer
zu seinen terminen
und einem 70 flüge wieder new york über
das stadtoberhaupt krisen häufig die
frage was sie für das verhältnis von
ihnen würde sich diese fast
freundschaftlich wird heißt weil wisse
lustig miteinander sehr lustig ja
einfach die geschichte war nie mit dem
darf verleiben sich für mich
verschwinden
zweiter wurde ferrari fahrer
entschlossen privatflugzeug probiert
haben mit einem karibik projekt geld
verdienen wird hängt von den verkäufen
ab und so tut er jetzt aus vermarkter
durch die hauptstädte der welt
das hotel in kopenhagen ist der letzte
schrei das zimmer riesig und gestylt
biotta hat eine handvoll potenzielle
kunden zusammen getrommelt bekannte und
geschäftsfreunde und sie in einem teuren
restaurant zum essen eingeladen
es ist wohl eine seiner kernkompetenzen
menschen mit geld zusammenzubringen
wir planen sogar unseren eigenen
landeplatzes verbindung zu den anderen
inseln
wir werden vier hotels haben davon eines
im soho stille ein anderes als trendiges
bohemien mäßiges strandhotel die runde
gibt sich interessiert kaufverträge
werden an diesem abend keine
unterschrieben
insgesamt lief es gut sagt ihr da die
hand sind das geht der 54 millionen
dollar verkauft das ist ein märchen dass
er waltenhofen sind sales bei der der
arzt und vor dem essen die optimistische
und und klar was sehr stark da
auch zu diesem thema kursieren im
internet zwar tiefere zahlen durch liga
sagt dieses einschaltet und nicht von
ihm ganz natürlicher prozesse was man
denken dass wir schon so dass das das
nie geschlossen ist eine ganz
infrastruktur machen die ja als erstes
hotel hof das hat hier doch dezember
das hatte er zwischen 2 und 5 2 villen
und die ganze infrastruktur der
golfplatz das sind das sind selber
sitzen also vorher ja da spricht gerne
von großen investitionen unklar bleiben
seine gewinne
wie sieht das bei seinem zweiten
wichtigen geschäft aus einer internet
plattform
in kopenhagen treffen sich am abend
mitglieder des netzwerks small world in
einer bar für 100 franken im jahr kommen
sie via internet in kontakt mit
gleichgesinnten aus der welt der reichen
und schönen
small world organisiert die treffen in
edlen clubs und hotels man erhält
vergünstigungen und wie ip
sonderbehandlung im jahr 2009 übernahm
jutta voigt die mehrheit an der firma
[Musik]
ich freue mich gleich spruch an der
firma fünf dass ich das war neben dem
studium abschlussexamen abgeguckt haben
dass ich die firma small world die
herren mit dem haken in q1 dienen dabei
der hollywood produzenten von den
abschließen
die haben ja umstellung geschrieben ich
bin aus new york für die ganze
kommunikation und der firma in rechtsweg
leider weniger spektakulär aus erwartet
ich habe etwas mitgebracht
das war vier jahre lang musste er massiv
geld nachschießen das habe ihn bisher
über 17 millionen gekostet
doch langsam bessere sich die lage smart
hat bis zum 30 juni operativ geld
verdient dass ich das ist ein punkt aber
das sind ja geschafft wo nicht suchen
was ich danach ich mache turnaround
management kriegen wir stehen aber gab
es hat mehr potenzial das heißt shopping
start sind würfel eigentlich das problem
und das haben jetzt die aus so geht es
weiter mit diesem schillernden hasardeur
durchbruch oder untergang
dass ein image gelitten hatten scheint
ihn wenig zu kümmern
ich bin ein charakter ich gemacht hat
wie alliander und dass das ist einfach
das ist kindergarten und primarschule
sexy und schwimmer und das dass das
verstanden dass ich aus learning von
monika hahn die mediale
berichterstattung letzter minute das er
hat sich in einem gemisch aufgestaut und
und das sagen die wirklich probiert
nachvollziehen und costa steht aber
warum macht er dann so weiter wie früher
seine villa wird in einem
lifestyle-magazin für 35 bis 81 1000
dollar die woche zur miete
ausgeschrieben
was er wirklich zahle sei privatsache
sagt er aber sicher nicht den vollen
betrag
und so scheint patrick liotard vogt
tatsächlich mehr zu leben aus zu
überleben
diesen luxus gönnt das nicht
[Musik]